- Well, the thing
about this mess is,
and I bring it up all the time,
certainly when I'm
talking to Dr. Drew
who still lives in California,
it's always, anytime
I talk to anyone
with a couple of brain
cells rubbed together,
it's like, they always go,
"Well, we gotta bottom out,
and we haven't quite
bottomed out yet,
but we'll bottom out, and
then when we bottom out,
then we'll change."
And I go, "Can't we see
ourselves bottoming out?"
Like, why do we always have
to completely bottom out?
You know what I mean?
It's basically like
saying, you know,
I got a 15-year-old daughter
and I had to remove all
the nail polish remover
from her room 'cause
she was huffing it,
and you go, "You wanna
get her some help?"
I gotta wait 'til she ODs.
Like I'll wait 'til
she flat lines,
and you go, "How about getting
her some counseling now?
She's drinking nail
polish remover."
"Yeah, but she hasn't flat,
she hasn't gone into
cardiac arrest."
It's like, yeah, oh, okay.
So California is bottoming out,
but we've not
utterly bottomed out,
and so we have to wait until
we physically make contact
with the floor of the basement
and then we'll go,
"You know, I think we gotta
get some new thoughts in here."
(upbeat music)
- I'm Dave Rubin,
and as you guys know,
I am off the grid for August
in an undisclosed location,
but we went ahead and
pre-taped some incredible,
fabulous, wonderful,
groundbreaking interviews
for you in July,
and joining me today
is the host of the
Adam Carolla Show,
and the author of many books.
I believe this is his sixth,
but his newest book,
right here in my hand,
"Everything Reminds
Me of Something:
Advice, Answers,
But No Apologies."
Adam Carolla, welcome
back to the Rubin Report.
- Always good to see you, Dave.
- Carolla, I have to have a
little mea culpa up top here.
I'm off the grid right now,
and as I'm interviewing you
just a few days before
the end of July,
I have not read the book yet
because I'm gonna
read it in August,
but is it fair to say this
is your best work ever?
- No, but it's up there.
(Dave laughs)
And you have to understand
my best work ever is
pretty damn funny.
This is pretty damn funny, too.
It's really hard to
kind of rank them.
People in 50 years,
will all be chicks
and they're like not
taco bell material,
but it's hard for me to do it,
but if you go on
Amazon, it had a 4.8.
It toggles between a
4.7 star and a 4.8 star.
My other books are 4.5, 4.6,
so yeah, it arguably is ranked
a little higher review-wise.
But it's up there.
Everything's above a 4.5.
- I think what you're
really trying to say
is that your best work
does involve a trampoline.
Is that what you're
really saying?
- And it's all in
the rear view mirror.
(Dave laughing)
- Speaking of the
rear view mirror,
I don't see you
in-person anymore
because I left California
in the rear view mirror.
You're still there,
you're on the short
list of sane people.
How's it going over there?
You all right?
Do you need any money or help?
What can I do for you?
- It's not good.
I know people always kind
of talk about the grid,
and wildfires, and homelessness,
and drug trafficking, and
street crime, and everything.
But I will sort of
paint you a picture
of how LA and
California is doing.
We tried to open a bridge
in LA like two weeks ago
and it had to be closed down
because too much street racing,
too many people climbing it
and threatening to jump off,
too much graffiti.
We literally attempted to open
a bridge in the middle of LA
to the tune of $600 million,
and two weeks after it was
opened, it's now closed
because the people
could not figure out
a way to walk across it
without tagging it,
threatening to jump off,
or sheaving somebody
with a shank.
That's where LA is.
- So you're saying
I made the right decision?
Is that what you're telling me?
- I think so.
I mean, you have bridges in
Florida and they're mostly open.
- Seem fine to me.
From what I can tell,
you're gonna get a gator
under 'em every now and again,
but they're functioning and
you just go to the other side.
And it's human there, it's okay.
- We're talking about putting
speed bumps in this bridge
and putting a medium
in the middle of it
because people can't
stop from doing donuts
in the middle of the bridge.
- I feel like the nonsense
of LA and California
must be particularly
hard for a guy like you.
Because when I think of you
first, you're very functional.
You like things that work.
You're a contractor, you
like things that make sense.
And yet you live in a place
where nothing makes sense.
Have you thought about
that spiritually?
- Yeah, if you're
wired the way I'm wired
and you're very
mechanical and pragmatic,
it does make no sense to,
you turn on the TV and the Los
Angeles Commissioner's Board
or the LA Council
Committee or whatever
is seven insane women
in their mid sixties
wearing masks on Zoom calls,
talking about re-masking the
kids before we open the schools
and comparing wearing a
mask to wearing shoes.
"You don't think wearing
shoes is restrictive.
It's more restrictive
than wearing a mask."
Just insane middle-aged
cows setting policy.
So yes, for a guy like me,
I would like somebody
with some experience
in the private sector,
making normal decisions
for the citizens.
- It's like being in a city run
by the ladies of "The View".
I really don't know how
you do it anyway, honestly.
- Yes.
- That's what you're up against.
- That's exactly what it is.
That's exactly what it is.
It's just a insane
cadre of yentas
who have feelings about
wearing masks and have,
it's like Rochelle
Walensky, head of the CDC,
when she was up there like,
"I'm speaking as a mother.
I have a bad feeling."
No one gives a shit about
your feelings, witch.
Just make some
policy, would you?
I don't care that...
Look how, all right, I'll
tell you what, I'm a dad.
And I got a bad feeling that
the schools are gonna be closed
and that my son's gonna have
to wear a mask for no reason.
So are we even now in
the feelings department?
- I feel like you
just gave Ben Shapiro
a great idea for his next book,
"No One Gives a About
Your Feelings Witch".
That feels like-
- Yes.
- You could co-write
that with him, I think.
- I'd love it.
- So I believe, because
I do do my research,
although I said I'm gonna
read this thing in August.
I believe in chapter four,
you say you're gonna stay
'til your kids are
out of high school
and then you're gonna
get the hell out.
Is that really the plan?
- Oh yeah.
You have to, you
can't run a business
or try to function in LA or
California any other way.
I mean, I guess you could
work for the TSA, I imagine,
and stay in California,
but you can't practically do it
if you're trying
to run a business.
So yes, I would have to leave.
- Speaking of the
craziness of the world,
as we're recording
this right now,
it sounds like we're
in a recession.
As of this morning, on July
28th, we are in a recession.
Although they have thus changed
the definition of
recession in real time
and edited on Wikipedia,
things don't seem to
be going very well.
- Did they edit it on Wikipedia?
Wow.
- As of today,
there's been 37 edits
on the official recession
page on Wikipedia.
But you can see it all over
on CNN, everybody's editing.
They're just, :A recession
isn't two consecutive quarters
of GDP going down.
Now, it also, there's
other factors,"
and the feelings
thing and all that.
- Yeah, it's really interesting.
I always think
about Kamala Harris
talking to Lester
Holt about the border.
And he's like, "Have
you been to the border?"
And she's like, "Oh, well,
yeah, we've been to the border."
"You've been to the border?"
"We have."
And then he goes, "But have
you been to the border?"
And she's like, "I
haven't been to Europe.
What are we talking about?"
The most interesting
thing about that exchange
is not her sort of lying,
it's her at the end she goes,
"I don't know what
you're asking."
"You don't know what I'm
asking, you're the Border Czar."
Let's just say you're the
queen of the Mardi Gras parade.
And I said, "Have you
been to Mardi Gras?"
Would you be confused and go,
"I don't know what
you're asking?"
That's the craziest part about
this sort of new world order,
which is like this weird
semantic overload thing
where we just get bogged
down and what is a recession?
What's a border, I don't know.
It's all invisible,
we can't define it.
What's a woman?
I can't.
- Yeah, exactly.
- So it's not definable?
So how are we gonna...
I mean, it's like you go in,
like when you're in the
sixth grade and you're like,
you go in and teacher's like,
"Did you bring your homework?"
And you went, "What's homework?"
"It's the assignment
that was assigned to you
when you left on Friday."
"I don't know what that...
Yes, I have seen homework, if
that's what you're asking."
It's just weird circle talk.
And it, by the way you dodged
a bullet 'cause you're gay.
But when you argue with
women, that's how you argue.
You start to talk about things-
- That's terrible.
- You don't even know what
you're talking about anymore.
And that's kind of
the new world order.
"What is a recession?"
"I don't know, here's
how I define it."
- Are you surprised?
- Well, here's how it's...
- Are you surprised that
all of this is so idiotic
that everyone involved with
all of this at every level
seems like a complete moron,
or in complete
dereliction of their duty,
or an idiot, or an
incompetent, or a psychopath.
I mean, you feel free to
use some other adjectives.
Like just the whole thing,
there's just nobody.
- Well, look, as
I've said many times,
if you can argue the
definition of what is a woman,
or the difference between
a man and a woman,
if that's open to debate,
then going to the
border or recession
is certainly on the table.
You know what I mean?
Like if you really think about
the ultimate black and white
definition, man, woman.
Okay, that's out the window.
So a recession, that's
easy to argue away.
If you can argue away a
woman, you know what I mean?
And I sort of think that's
the motivation for a lot of it
because they will
argue away anything now
because everything
is on the table.
Now the question you're
sort of asking is,
well, Joe Biden, Kamala
Harris, whomever,
I get it, that's their job.
But I mean, it's insane, but
that's what they're doing.
The question is more like, what
are the news outlets doing?
Aren't they worried
about their credibility?
Don't they sound insane.
I mean, I get it, you're
a cheerleader for a party.
But you're essentially saying,
I'm a cheerleader
in a football game,
and the other team just scored.
And you go, "No, they didn't."
It's like, "Yes they did."
"No, well, what is your
definition of a touchdown then?"
It's like, CNN,
you sound insane.
And people stopped listening.
And why are you making
this deal with the devil?
Why are you cashing in every
bit of goodwill you've earned
over the last 50 years
on stupid things.
Just give it up.
Or going like all
in on January 6th,
it's the worst, democracy
hanging by a thread,
the worst attack
since Pearl Harbor,
like you're a news outlet.
Or Ivermectins for horses.
Why are you giving it up?
Why are you playing so fast
and loose with your dignity.
You're a news outlet.
We don't listen anymore.
- Do you think it's too late?
And we should just
encourage their slow,
or I guess at this point,
they're relatively quick death.
It's been a slow death, but
I think it's now escalating.
- I don't know.
My feeling is if somebody
popped on to MSNBC and said,
"Look, we traditionally
define a recession
as two quarters of
negative growth.
And that's what we got
so that's what we're in."
I'd go, all right,
well, at least that guy
sounds semi-sane.
- Right, but there aren't too
many of those guys over there.
But you know, I've
asked you this before,
but I don't think we've
done anything on camera
since you brought me back from
off the grid last September.
So about 11 months ago.
You're a Hollywood guy,
you've had a lot of
success in Hollywood,
you still live in LA.
When you think
about all of these,
the people that
you're talking about
that are just sort of
in on all of the lies,
I mean, an awful lot of
the Hollywood people,
they're just kind of in the lie.
Do you get invited to
any parties anymore?
When's the last time you've
been out of the house?
- Well, I'm out now
technically but-
- Not to your own building.
- Since you left, I don't get
invited to too many parties.
(Dave laughing)
- Is it really like that?
- There's an element.
Yes, there's a strong element
of not getting invited
to things you used
to get invited to,
for sure, yeah.
Not with certain friends,
or older friends,
or guys I've known
for a long time,
or that sort of stuff.
But yeah, sure, there's
an element of that.
That's what they do.
First off they're cowards,
secondly, they're into
McCarthyism big time,
which is weird 'cause they
never shut up about McCarthyism,
but they love to
practice McCarthyism
every chance they get
and then they complain
more about McCarthyism.
So yeah, that's
what Hollywood does.
- Tell me about the book here.
Because when I saw the cover
here, and I saw the title,
"Everything Reminds
Me of Something",
I thought, this is Carolla,
because that's you, right?
Like, when you're
doing your show,
everything that you hear,
you're interviewing somebody,
you're doing the news,
everything reminds
you of something
that happened way back when.
That is the Adam Carolla.
- Yeah.
It's something, it came out of
my mouth like five years ago
and I went, "Yeah, that's true.
Everything does remind
me of something."
And I thought it'd be a
good title for a book.
And the book is people
asking questions
versus me sitting down and
posing my own questions,
which is kind of what you
do when you write a book.
You go, well, here's
what I wanna talk about,
and here's...
And it's an interesting
conceit because it's like,
authoring a book is sort of
asking yourself a question.
Like, what should we do
about the homeless problem?
Here's what we need to do
about the homeless problem.
But this is a little different
in that people were
asking me questions,
and I had to form
thoughts and opinions
on questions that I
wasn't asking myself.
So I found myself going,
"Hmm, yeah, why is that?"
And then I was kind of
pushed outside of my box
and had to figure out what is
the answer to that question?
Because they were not my own.
- Yeah, what's like
the most burning thing
that you were asked
that you really maybe
hadn't thought through.
You're a thinker, you're
doing a daily podcast, man.
You talk to people
on the internet.
- The one that pops into my
head, and there were many,
but the one I remember.
And you also, people have
to remember or consider,
I write these books,
I write 'em while I'm
doing 10 other things.
And then they come out,
and then people go,
"What's your favorite chapter?"
Whatever it is, I can't
remember anything.
I was there, I did it-
- Yeah, publish it.
- And now I'm gone.
and I don't know.
But somebody said,
in a world that's very
equitable now in 2022
where males and females
sort of share a lot
of the same duties
and there's more women
in college these days,
and more women attorneys
than male attorneys,
why is it when you
see a motorcycle
going down the road
with a couple on it,
the guy is still the guy with
his hands on the handlebars,
and the woman is
pulled in behind him
with her hands on his waist.
Why?
And I was like, yeah.
- I have some thoughts,
I'll let you answer
your own question.
- No, I'm see...
Now this is what happened to me.
I was like, yeah, I never
thought of that, but it's true.
I've not seen any
women riding the bike
with the guy on the back.
But in a world where
the guy stays home
and takes care of the kids
and the woman goes to work
and he's making
dinner and everything,
all the responsibilities
are shared now,
why do we still have
this in this one place?
Also, it's like,
see a lot of women driving
with the guy in the
passenger seat now.
You didn't see that so
much when I was growing up.
So I'll be curious
your take on that.
And then I'll tell
you what I said.
- Well, first on the why
the man is always driving
when the woman's in the car,
I never understood
that growing up.
It was like a running
joke in my family
because I knew my mom
knew how to drive,
she'd somehow drive
us to get ice cream
or go play basketball.
But somehow if my
dad was in the car,
it was as if my mom had no
ability to drive whatsoever.
Sometimes we'd be
fighting in the back
and my dad would turn to my mom.
"You wanna drive and
I'll deal with them?"
And my mom would freak out
as if she has no idea
where any of the shift, and
the wheel, and the whole thing.
On the first part was the,
why are men on the
front of the bicycle,
on the bike and the
women on the back.
I think it's actually
because a lot of traditional
gender roll stuff
does make sense,
and people actually,
it's not even that
they crave it,
they sort of automate
towards it either way.
And it's not to say there
aren't things that are good
that can be a
little bit different
than that sort of
ideal situation,
but I think it's just how it is.
It would be odd,
it would be odd,
but not impossible
if you saw the chick
holding the motorcycle
and the guy holding her.
It just, it doesn't
fully compute.
It's not impossible,
it just kind of is.
Men are usually more
protectors, you know.
Hunter gatherer,
the whole thing.
- But we have like admirals
who are transgender now
and stuff, you know?
I mean, like we are all...
I get it that's the way it was,
but those rules
don't apply to 2022.
Everything has
been flipped over,
and turned over, and changed.
I'll tell you the real answer.
- [Dave] Please.
- The real answer is the couples
that would be considered
a progressive couple,
the couple I spoke of,
the couple where maybe
the guy stays home
and does the dishes,
and the woman goes
to work and all that,
they would never
own a motorcycle.
- Yeah.
- They're scared.
The motorcycle's way,
these are double master
couples we're talking about.
This is wipe everything
down with Purell,
this is put a helmet on the
kid when he goes outside.
That's who they are.
A motorcycle's far too
dangerous for that couple.
They would never
own a motorcycle.
The couples that do
own the motorcycles
who are willing to deal with
the danger of a motorcycle
are old school couples.
So they have, and I bet
their life reflects that.
I bet in that couple,
the guy goes to work
and the woman stays home
and raises the kids
and what have you.
So you only see traditional
folks on the motorcycles
'cause they would
never have a motorcycle
in a progressive relationship.
Too fear-based.
- So basically,
they've self selected
themselves in.
Is it kind of fun
for you in a way now,
like when you're doing standup,
or you're doing your show,
or you're writing a book
that it's like, you're
mostly a libertarian,
and at least in my eyes,
I don't know if you officially
call yourself anything.
But that this sort of like
basically rough sanity
is now starting to be funny.
Like that's actually
starting to work
while the woke stuff and all
the crappy Netflix Specials
by these not-really-comedian
comedians,
nobody's watching any of them.
- Yeah, we've come to the point
where you can kind of make
fun of people who are insane.
And somehow there's a little
light at the end of the tunnel.
We're in LA, we're talking
about bringing masks back,
and there are people now who go,
"I'm not going along
with this, this is nuts."
They didn't say anything
a year and a half ago,
but they're starting to
wake up a little bit.
And so you can kind of
do that on stage now too
whereas two years ago,
I mean I did anyway,
but people are freaked
out about everything.
You can slowly start to make fun
of the insane masked up
transgenderized world
that we've created.
- Suddenly, as you
were saying that,
I'm reminded of a clip.
You had Gavin
Newsom on your show,
what like a decade
ago or something?
- Yeah, a little less, but yeah.
- You had Gavin Newsom
so maybe eight years ago,
something like that.
And you smacked him
around pretty good.
Which I have to tell you,
as a guy that fled the
state because of that guy
made me feel pretty good.
Do you hold that one?
Does that have a special
place in your heart?
- Yeah, it is.
People can see it on YouTube,
if they like, I imagine,
I think it's out there.
He came in here,
I didn't really have anything
against him per se, at the time.
He agreed to come
in and sit down
and did kind of a long
form interview with him.
There's a couple of caveats.
A, he came in, he
would never come in
to a place like this now
or anything near anything
like that, number one.
Number two, it wasn't
a quick hit on News 11,
it was as long as we had.
And so he couldn't
escape, he couldn't...
There was no segment that
ended in three minutes
and he was gonna take off
with his security detail.
He was just trapped
in the studio with me.
And I wasn't planning
on going after him.
I don't really work that way.
My idea, when I
interview people is just,
I wanna interview people,
but I will ask 'em questions.
And he started off.
So I don't think
people really know
how intellectually
troubled he is,
or bankrupt, or something.
I don't really know whether
they're call him a liar,
or an imbecile, or just a
sellout, or whatever it is.
But I don't-
- I prefer soulless frankly,
I just believe he
has no human soul.
That's just me.
- There's something
wrong with him.
And what I mean is
like Kamala Harris,
there's something
wrong with her.
And that when Lester
Holt is asking,
have you've been to the border,
she doesn't know
what he's saying.
Like there's a synapse problem,
there's something wrong.
Now look, you can
just lie and just go,
"Yeah, I haven't been
to the border yet,
but I'm closely
monitoring the border
and I'm planning on
going later this week."
Just lie.
But to go, I don't
know what you're asking
means something's
wrong with you?
And something's
wrong with a lot of,
Biden has something
wrong with him,
obviously, Kamala Harris,
Newsom has something
wrong with him.
And so there's a
couple of things.
One is, I said to him,
look, traffic is
horrible in this town.
Can we work on
traffic a little bit?
And he said, yeah...
First off, it's all
kind of news to him.
He's like, "Well, what
do you want me to do?"
It's this weird thing
where they don't know...
You don't sit in traffic?
Like you you're kind of unaware.
And so I said a few things.
I said in Idaho, there's signs
by the side of the highway
that says, if it's
steers, it clears.
And in LA, I see people
in the third lane
on the 405 freeway,
both people out of their car
because they had a
little bumper bender.
The cars are fine,
no airbags deployed,
and they're like standing
in the third lane,
exchanging information.
And my thing is like, pull over,
pull off to the shoulder.
And it's like, we got
into a car accident.
I know, the car's fine.
Just pull it over and
get your information.
A, people get killed that
way, it happens often,
and B, you you've
stopped the whole freeway
because you guys are
having a conversation
in the middle of the freeway
and your cars run.
I said, put it up
on the freeway sign.
Just, if it steers, it clears.
They have 'em in all
the different states.
And so the first thing
he went was he went,
"Ah, really?"
Get out of here, kind of thing.
And I said, "No, they have it."
He's like, "I never
heard of that."
So he never heard of that.
And then he rebutted
it with this,
and this is what makes Gavin,
this is why something is
wrong with Gavin Newsom.
He said, "You know, I'll
tell you I saw something."
He started chuckling.
He goes, "I saw
something I liked.
I saw a sign I liked.
It said, "You're not in
traffic, you are traffic."
And I kinda like that."
And I'm like, I don't
know what that means,
but it certainly doesn't feel
like a way to alleviate
the problem of traffic.
(Dave laughing)
So it's an insane statement to
say, you're not, you know...
It's like, "I'm an oncologist.
You don't have cancer,
you are cancer.
All right, my work is done."
Like, I don't know what
he's talking about.
Then he said, I heard
him in another interview
when he went on to
a friendly show.
But the person, the woman
who was interviewing him,
at least had enough
dignity to say,
"Hey, people are
fleeing California."
This was a recent interview.
"What are we gonna
do about that?
I mean, you have thoughts
about people just
leaving California?"
And he said, "You know,
my answer to that is,
where else you gonna go?"
And the host said-
- I can think
of at least one place.
- Yeah.
The host said, "I don't know,
Florida, Texas, Nashville,
like just anywhere."
And then he said, "Yeah, I know.
I look, no, I didn't say that,
Jerry Brown used to say that."
So he quoted a guy,
and then disavowed himself
of whatever the quote was,
Jerry Brown in 1974 would say,
"Where else you're gonna go."
And so Gavin Newsom
decided to repeat that.
And when the person said,
"Yeah, but that
doesn't make sense."
He went, "Yeah, I know,
Jerry Brown said that."
Which means you're,
it means you're insane,
it means you have a problem,
it means you're not
thinking correctly.
And then he started up with me.
I said, "The homeless..."
This is nine years ago.
I said, "The homeless problem
is crazy people, and
junkies, and both.
That's who's homeless."
And then he said,
"Let me explain to you
the real face of homelessness."
He prefaced it by saying
that was his main issue
and that's what he
cared about the most.
And then he explained to me
the real face of homelessness,
the real picture of homelessness
was a mother of three
whose husband left,
and who had a minimum wage job
and was forced out
into the streets.
And I said, that's not who
is living on the streets.
- It's a very specific example.
- His number one issue
was homelessness.
He said he was
passionate about it.
Then went on to explain a
scenario that doesn't exist.
And now that was nine years ago
and homelessness
is tenfold worse.
So that's who Gavin Newsom is.
And I don't know, I really,
I'm always curious why
the people around him go,
"Don't say that."
Or like, "That's not the..."
The problem of homelessness
is not mothers of three
who are making minimum wage.
- What do you make of the people
that are bamboozled by him?
And by the way,
the only reason I'm even
asking you about him,
besides the fact
that for some reason,
you're still there
and I've fled,
is that I'm pretty sure that,
as you know, because I'm
off the grid at the moment,
I could come back and he
could be vice president,
'cause I think this whole thing
is completely out of control,
they're keeping Biden
alive on God knows what,
and he visited the white house
when Joe went off to Israel.
- Vice president? Interesting.
- But you figure out something
to get Nancy out of the
way, something like that.
- You get Kamala and Gavin
Newsom in the same room
and you are gonna have
a nothing circle talk
of complete and utter insanity.
We're literally
gonna have two people
who make no sense and
who don't track at all.
What I make of it is, LA,
California, especially,
and then people in general,
they're very sort
of, and Hollywood,
you go now why did Hollywood?
They loved Obama,
they love Newsom.
Like why?
They're aesthetically oriented.
And I don't mean it's all about
like matinee idol good looks.
They just kind of go,
if they said, look, I'm
gonna show you a picture.
I'm gonna take
everyone in Hollywood
and I'm gonna show
you a picture.
Show you a picture Gavin Newsom,
and I'm gonna show you a
picture of Donald Trump,
who do you want as a
pilot in your airplane?
They'll go, "Oh, I want
that guy with the jawline.
For sure, he's a
much better pilot.
He's gotta be.
Look at this guy.
This guy's eating
a cheeseburger.
Look at this guy,
that guy's my pilot."
It's literally like they're
casting a movie all the time.
Like, George Clooney looks
like he knows what he's doing.
And they're so
aesthetically oriented
and sort of paper thin.
And there's such this
weird living life
on kind of the veneer
surface of life that they go,
"Look at that guy.
Yeah, look at Obama, that guy."
And then you go, "Well,
let's talk about policies."
And they go, "No, no,
no, no, let's not get.
Let's admire that,
look at that guy.
I'd like to have a
beer with that guy."
That's basically what
they do with Gavin Newsom.
They're idiots.
But that's how it works.
That's literally...
Why does Hollywood...
Hollywood hated with a
red hot burning fever,
they hated Trump.
A lot of that was just,
it was an aesthetic and a style.
They just was driven so nuts
by his look and his mannerisms
that they just didn't
care about anything else.
They just hated him.
Where would that hatred, weird
visceral hatred come from.
They're so shallow
that they work based
basically on an aesthetic.
They love AOC for that reason.
I was on Hannity a month
ago and I just went,
"If AOC was a middle-aged
chubby chick from Minnesota,
would anyone listen to
a word she had to say?"
And then everyone turned
on me and they're like,
"How could you say that?"
It's like, what do you
mean how could I say it?
'Cause it's patently true.
- If she was Amy Klobuchar,
everyone would think she'd be
as popular as Amy Klobuchar.
- That's right,
that's exactly right.
- What do we do to
get out of this mess
that we seem to be stuck in?
- Well, the thing
about this mess is,
and I bring it up all the time,
certainly when I'm
talking to Dr. Drew
who still lives in California.
It's always, anytime
I talk to anyone
with a couple of brain
cells rubbed together,
it's like, they always go,
"Well, we gotta bottom out,
and we haven't quite
bottomed out yet,
but we'll bottom out.
Then when we bottom
out, then we'll change."
And I go, "Can't we see
ourselves bottoming out."
Like, why do we always have
to completely bottom out?
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
It's basically like saying,
I got a 15-year-old daughter,
and I had to remove
all the nail polish
remover from her room
'cause she was huffing it.
And you go, "You wanna
get her some help?"
"I gotta wait 'til she ODs.
I'll wait 'til she flat lines."
And you go, yeah, how about
getting her some counseling now?
She's drinking nail
polish remover.
Like yeah, but she hasn't
gone into cardiac arrest.
Yeah, okay.
So California is bottoming out,
but we've not
utterly bottomed out.
And so we have to wait
until we physically make contact
with the floor of the
basement, and then we'll go,
"You know, I think we gotta
get some new thoughts in here."
- Is the bizarre
part of that too,
that there is no such
thing as the floor there.
Like no one would ever agree.
Oh now it can't get
worse than this because,
I was only there
for eight years,
but it just got worse and worse.
It was not terrible
when I got there,
then obviously
COVID escalated it.
But it's like, you're right,
everybody that I
would see in LA,
"Oh well it's gotta get
worse before it gets better."
That's what they always say.
"It's gotta get worse
before it gets better
to wake up people."
I don't think people
will ever agree
on how worse it has to get.
- No, you're right.
It's basically, you
have an NFL coach,
he's three and 13 every year.
And then you go, "Shouldn't
we get a new coach?"
And I go, "Wait till
we go one in 15."
(Dave laughing)
- The problem is,
you're not drafting anybody to
California to save the place.
If you had a draft
pick involved,
maybe this thing makes sense.
But there are no draft
picks as far as I know.
Are all your friends leaving?
- A lot of 'em?
Well, I would say
probably more people
who are more
conservative are leaving,
and the less conservative ones
are kind of riding it out.
And also, there's a version
of living in California
where you just
make a ton of money
and kind of hang out in Malibu
where you can sort of go,
"Eh, wherever that bridge is,
they built and Boyle Heights,
I'm not going over that bridge.
I'm going on the Malibu Pier."
There's definitely
a lot of that.
- You're having breakfast
at Nobu, aren't you,
you elitist?
- Yes, that's right.
And go to Soho House
afterward for lunch.
- Adam, what's wrong
with Joe Biden?
I've been trying
to figure it out.
I think something's
wrong with the guy.
You kind of alluded to it.
What's wrong with the man?
- Well, I would say there's,
if you're gonna
try to figure out
what's wrong with Joe Biden,
you have to kind of
break it off into stages,
kind of early, middle,
and present day Joe Biden.
The beginning part
of Joe Biden was,
and I don't think
people really took
a big enough accounting of this.
But when he was like,
"I was at the head of
my law school class,
I was the only student
with a dual degree,
and a dual major,
and two whatever.
And I did 15,000 on the SATs.
All right, buddy?
you wanna do a push up contest?"
And then later on it was like,
yeah, he was at the
bottom of his class,
he never got a degree, and
he didn't take the SATs.
Someone should have pumped the
brakes right there and went,
"That's a sociopath.
There's something wrong."
Now look, I was,
I don't like to talk
about myself, Dave, but.
- No, no, no, no.
Please, I'll grant
you this one time.
- I was...
Just this one moment
and then we can go back.
Your listeners can enjoy.
I was first team,
All-Central Valley
at North Hollywood
High in football.
And every once in a while,
somebody's talking, and
I'm doing an interview,
we're on some sports
show or something,
they go, "Adam was an
All-City football player."
And I go, "No, not All-City.
I wasn't All-City,
that's higher."
I was All-Valley,
All-Central Valley.
So get it straight."
Now, why?
Well, the answer is
I wasn't All-City.
And I'm just not comfortable
with being labeled All-City
when I was all valley,
a lower degree.
So there's something wrong
with his character, number one,
that he would just plagiarize,
and lie, and lie, and lie.
Now, he's sort of
sociopathic that way.
Now, there's obviously
some cognition issues
that are going on now,
which have just
exacerbated what he was.
Now, when people ask him,
did you ever talk
to your son about,
he's like, "Hey
bud, I never talked.
Hey Dutch, hey Duke, hey Bob,
I, I, hey Mark, I didn't talk,
I never said what?"
And it's like he has
no ability to go,
"Well, look, every..."
First off, if your son owned
a frozen yogurt
place in Pasadena,
you would talk to him
about his business
on Thanksgiving dinner, right?
You'd go "Son, how's
the software going?"
And he'd go-
- Hey, hey, hey, hey.
- Winter months are tough.
- Don't shit talk
to Pinkberry in Pasadena, okay?
- That's right.
- The mango is pretty
solid over there.
- Too late.
The point is I've
never talked to my son
ever about any of his...
It's like, well that makes you
a horrible dad, doesn't it?
- Right, right, right.
- But he has this thing
where now he's angered
if anyone challenges him.
He does not have,
there's no gray area.
When somebody talks about,
go back, just go back and
look at all the clips.
Like during the
debates with Trump.
It's like, "Hey, you had
business dealings with China."
" I never did any,
I don't have anyone.
It's him, it's
Trump did, he did."
It's like, your son's all over
business dealings with China.
Like, you can say, "Hey,
it's a nuanced subject."
When you become a politician,
you meet a lot of people,
you don't know
who you're taking a photo
off with all the time.
I'm not, you know,
I can't keep track,
I don't look at my calendar
down to the last second.
So yeah, probably met a
few guys from a few places,
and I get what it looks like,
but I never profited
off it or whatever.
He's just like, 100% never
happened, shut it down, no.
He is really kind of sociopathic
and I don't think people
really fully understand it.
I mean, his tells are,
whenever he says true story,
true story, or whatever,
he's always lying,
or whenever he says the word
truth, there's a lie there.
But also, telling those stories,
like where he's saying,
1953, I'd be walking with my dad
through the streets of Scranton,
and we'd see two fellas hugging.
And my dad would
look at me and go,
"That's what love is son?"
And I said, "You know
what, you're right dad."
That never happened,
that never happened.
And Kamala Harris was
marching with Harriet Tubman,
and wanted freedom
when she was two.
It's like...
Why doesn't this
bother people more?
This kind of weird...
And then what people
do is they go,
"Well, look at Trump.
Yeah, Trump said there were a
million people at inauguration
and there were 700,000
people at the inauguration."
I get it, he's a boaster,
he's an exaggerator.
He's not inserting
himself like Zelig
into pieces of history
that never happened,
or just lying about,
"I have two degrees."
You don't have one degree.
"I was at the head
of my law school."
You were at the bottom,
in the bottom 10%.
That's insane.
And it's a tell.
And most people don't take it
as a tell, but they should.
- You think he's gonna
make it all the way?
I mean, you kind of hit
on the mental stuff,
something ain't right.
- Look, I don't know,
maybe you and I we're
early money on this,
but a year ago, a
year and a half ago,
they were like, "You
think he's running for..."
I said, "No, he's not
running for a second term."
They were like, "Why not?
You don't think he
wants to be pre..."
I was like, " He's
not gonna be here.
He's not gonna be
able to physically..."
I was on Bill Mar's
show, and he was like,
"Is he gonna run?"
And you know, "Of
course he's gonna run."
And I said, "He's
gonna run for..."
I said, he can barely walk.
Forget about running
for president, no.
And I said early, I don't
know if he's making it
out of the first term.
He may.
- On Inauguration Day,
I think I said, I'll
retire, I'll end my show
if he makes it through
the whole first term.
I think I'm looking
pretty good at the moment.
But let me, you mentioned-
- Look, if they wanna prop
him up and just sort of,
if they wanna do
what they wanna do,
if the news outlets and
the mainstream media,
and everyone wants to just
kind of circle the wagons
and prop him up,
I suppose they could ride it out
if they really wanna go
down that route, that hole.
Sorry, go ahead.
- No, no, well,
you mentioned Mar,
and I talk about Mar
a lot on this show.
Whatever parties you're
still invited to,
I'm gonna get you disinvited
to all of them right now.
'Cause I talk about more a lot,
like sort of as the,
he's the prototypical sort of,
I'm not a crazy woke Lefty,
I'm good on free speech,
I'm against CRT, I'm
against the gender stuff,
I finally came out
against lockdowns,
I'm sane on most of this stuff,
the conservatives
always applaud him,
then he calls them racist,
they get upset for a minute,
then he says something
sane, they applaud again.
What do you think
is going on there?
And do you think there's a
way to get a guy like him
to get over the hump and realize
that the people
that he's supporting
are importing all of
the stuff that he hates.
- He's a guy who's
intellectually honest
who can be a little
naive sometimes
in that, I remember he had
Adam Schiff on his show,
maybe a year ago.
He did the one-on-one
interview with him.
And he said,
and this is kind of him
being intellectually honest
and naive at the same time.
He's like, "Look, Adam, you
come on my show, you go on CNN,
you go on Anderson Cooper,"
you know what I mean?
"What you really need to do
is go on Hannity or go on Tucker
and straighten
those people out."
You know what I mean?
"You were preaching to the
choir on Joy Reed Show,
go on Hannity.
I wish that guy would
put you on his show
so you could go over there."
Adam Schiff, 'cause
he's a coward
sort of mumbled
under his breath,
"I've been invited a few times."
And then Bill Mar
who's naive was like,
"Well then why not go?"
Because he'd get his ass handed
to him because he's a liar.
And they would have facts,
and he would be destroyed.
Yeah, okay, go talk
to Ben Shapiro,
go talk to Dennis Prager,
go talk to those guys.
They never talk to those guys
'cause they get destroyed.
Or Gavin Newsom, come
on back for round two.
Come on back pussy.
Let's have it out.
Bring a notepad, I won't
write anything down.
How about it?
Come on back.
He won't come back 'cause
he'll be destroyed.
So Mar is a little naive like,
"Hey, go on to Hannity
and go coach him up."
So that's kind of
the naive part.
The other part of him,
that's sort of honest
and hopeful is,
"Yeah, you got a message to
spread, why wouldn't you,
why do you keep going
to the people that are already
converted, go outside."
I said the same thing
about Fauci the whole time.
You all these
unwashed Walmart shop
and gun-toting Hannity
watching people.
They're not getting the
vaccine, they're not wearing,
they're not getting the message.
We gotta get to those people.
Well, don't do it on
Joy Reed Show, Fauci,
go on Hannity and
straighten everyone out.
But you won't
because you're coward
and you know
there'd be pushback,
and they'd ask questions,
and you couldn't
answer those questions.
So you won't.
But it's insane for
someone like Fauci
who's trying to spread
the message to the Right
who won't go on
shows of the Right.
That's an interesting conceit.
And also that this bullshit
where people are like,
"Well, he wouldn't
be treated fairly."
What do you mean treated fairly?
Gavin Newsom can
come into my studio
and say whatever the
fuck Gavin Newsom wants,
I'm allowed to push back.
He then is allowed
to correct me.
What do you mean treated fairly?
I love that notion.
No, he's not gonna
be treated fairly.
No, he's not, he's gonna
be treated like a guest,
and there's gonna be a debate.
Now, go ahead and
bring all your facts
and beat up Tucker
with your information.
- It's funny 'cause
I get that too.
They'll say, "Okay, well you
wouldn't treat 'em fairly."
And it's like,
for all these people that
I make fun of all the time,
I've never treated
a guest poorly once.
I've never treated any guest
any differently than
any other guest.
There are people who
maybe I agree with more,
but I treat these
people all the same,
and I would treat any of
these people with respect.
But I would ask hopefully the
right questions along the way.
But you're right,
that their stuff is so thin
that they know you can kind
of just poke right through it.
So they'd rather
call us Nazis, Adam.
- Yeah, so Mar, who I know well,
and who's a good guy,
his basic conceit,
and I think it's the same
with many Democrats and many
people in California for sure,
which is, look, there's
too much regulation,
there's too much red tape,
housing is too expensive,
taxes are too high, and
wildfires, and water shortages,
and the schools suck, fine.
But would you really want
a racist running the state?
- Like that's all,
that's all at the end.
You really think that
he really believes it.
I think you're probably right.
- That's basically how it comes,
that's just what
it comes down to.
And then the people that
have a bunch of money
and send their kids
to private school go,
"Yeah, you know what,
I don't care that
there's traffic,
and I don't care that
the grid is broken,
we're running out of water.
I just would not want
some homophobic bigot
running the state."
Or as the president or whatever,
and they go, "So
it's still better."
And you know, maybe
the answer is,
yeah, if that were true.
I mean, if Larry Elder
was the actual black face
of white supremacy or something,
or Dennis Prager was
a white supremacist,
then I would tend to agree.
I'd still be a little more
pragmatic and probably go,
well I'm white, so what
do I got to worry about?
But yeah, I would go,
yeah, I know people that are
gay, or black, or something.
Yeah, I would not wanna vote
for the Hitlerian, Stalinesque
dictator, whatever.
But they're not intellectually
honest enough to go,
what do you mean he's a racist?
Where's that coming from?
Oh, the LA Times said he was.
Oh, okay.
But the don't they
call everyone a racist?
As you said, and I
quote you all the time,
"How could it be that everyone
who disagrees with our side
when you are on the
Left is a racist?"
How's that
mathematically possible?
That's our argument.
- The equation just
stopped working for me.
- "I'm gonna build
a desalination plant
in Redondo Beach."
"Oh, because you're racist?"
(Dave laughing)
Like, is everything race?
I mean, you just
disagree with everything?
Is that race, I like
fracking and cheap oil.
Okay, I get it,
homophobe, I get it.
- Yeah, transphobe.
Carolla, I'm gonna save
my most important question
for our locals community
for the subscribers
because I'm a greedy
capitalist, AKA racist.
We're gonna do that
in just a second.
Is there anything else
you want the good people
to know about, about the book,
which we're gonna
link to down below
because we're a
professional program.
- It's a very funny book.
Go to Amazon, read the reviews.
If you like, what
you read, go get it
and you will laugh.
And in a world where
there's a lot of problems
and people are pretty serious,
having a laugh is probably
gonna be good for your soul.
- Adam Carolla, good luck
in California, my friend.
- Thank you.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about comedy,
instead of the nonstop yelling
you get everywhere else,
check out our comedy playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
check out our full
episode playlist,
they're both right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification.